[موسيقى]
أنا في طريقي إلى الضفاف الخارجية الجنوبية
وشاطئ البحر الوطني ،
وهو امتداد نقي وغير مأهول من الرمال يبلغ
طوله 56 ميلاً والطريقة الوحيدة للوصول إلى
هناك هي عن طريق القوارب ، يأخذ معظم السياح
العبارة السريعة للجزيرة بعد قارب سريع
اركب ، لقد اصطفت النحلة إلى المكان
مع أروع
المناظر ، المنارة التاريخية ، أشعر وكأننا
نستطيع رؤيتها حتى نهاية العالم هنا
اشرح لي هذه المنطقة ، الشيء المدهش
هو أننا على حافة الهاوية ونحن على
حافة  ولايتنا
ولدت دولتنا ألتون
بلانتس وترعرعت في جزيرة أوكراكوك القريبة عندما كنت طفلاً
كنت أرغب في أن أكون هناك على الماء
وأتقدم على
الشاطئ في مكان ما ألتون لديه شغف عميق
بهذه الجزر من حيث
جمالها وحيويتها.  قصة
ما وراء ما نراه مرصودًا للرأس ،
أنت تعرف المياه الضحلة الغادرة لرصد الرأس
حيث تتواجد الأمواج المتصادمة
وهذا ما يدقك إلى أشلاء
خاصة في الليل العاصف مع
الطقس غير المتوقع والمياه الضحلة الضحلة
هذا  أصبحت المنطقة تُعرف باسم
مقبرة الأطلسي
، حيث استسلمت آلاف السفن بما في ذلك سفن الجاليون والسفينة السوداء
لقوى الطبيعة ، ومن هنا كانت الحاجة إلى
هذه المنارة وعلى هذه
الجزر الحاجزة كانت في السابق محطات لخفر السواحل
وحتى المدن الصغيرة التي اختفت منذ ذلك الحين
في  الأرض التي
التقيت بها مع رجل آخر هوبر غوثري
الذي اكتشف هذه الشواطئ عندما كان طفلاً
أراني في المسافة الجزيرة
التي عاش فيها أسلافه ذات يوم
هنا ، كانت البنوك
المقيدة على ضفاف شاكلفورد مدينة تسمى
مدينة الألماس وربما كان بها أربعة  أو
خمسمائة شخص بالفعل في إحدى
المرات التي ذهبنا فيها لإلقاء نظرة فاحصة على
ضفاف شاكلفورد ومن القارب يمكننا أن نرى
تذكيرًا حيًا بالتاريخ القاسي
للبنوك الخارجية هناك وهم
خيول شاكلفورد
الخيول البرية التي كانت الأسطورة قبل حوالي 400
عام  هناك جاليون إسباني
أتى مع تلك الخيول غرقت السفينة
وهذه الخيول تسبح إلى الشاطئ هنا على
قيد الأسطوري  تعيش خيول ضفاف شاكلفورد
على الوافد الجديد نسبيًا إلى هذا
الامتداد الخالد من المستنقعات البحرية والشواطئ
المحمية الآن بواسطة خدمة المتنزهات
الوطنية وهذا المكان هو مكان رائع
لتتدحرج فيه أفكارك وتدور
حولها تمامًا مثل كل هؤلاء  موجات نراها